the follow scholars this is then in the
pepper's with gifts journal
in this word a one hundred and twenty
one layer convolutional neural network
is trained to recognize
demoniah en ferti in the friendly caesar's the
monia is an inflammatory ylang
condition that is responsible for a
million hospitalization  en 15 phase des
pères here in the us alone
such a great and requires the training set
of formidable size to work properly
this means a bunch of input-output pers
in this case one training simple is an
input frontally extreme age of the chest
and the  eight pulsar annotations at
experts from mark youtube de for the
inside the 6 percent in december
zo dc like this in which contains
demoniah hier en dit 1000 this is mattias
te binary yes or no answer
but in more detail advice map of
possible regions that fit de  die knaus
is the training set used for the tiger
itam can offer one hundred thousand
images of tarly thousand pensions
this is then give in to duo  network and
its task is to learn the properties of
the sith is by itself
then after the learning process to place
previously unseen images of the vintage
and greet' him en
set of radiology this is code testset and
of course it is crucial
het bos de training  and the test sets
unreliable
has the training and per set is creative
by one expert 2 who looks all just and this
week game benchmarks in your network
guests different randomly
radiologist that's not a very liable
process speakers each of the humans may
be drunk in modern few cases  capable
the training and tessa of notation dh
discreet in by asking module radiology
and taking
and majority vote discover this season
sauna that the training knows std is wie
liable
weekend properly benchmark filming versus
on your own at work and tears the result
with learning a good  time out performs
the edge you man radiologist
the performance was measured in the to the
space where sensitivity and
specificity are important interesting
m  atrix sensitive team is the proportion
of positive samples that word classified
is positive and
pacific damiens the portion of
negative samos that is
classified negative the scratches mee in the film and
doctors and this you can see what ever
radiology to look at ease and though
they  have very different for positive and
negative regions de er already locate this
bureau the blue bear boogy no yesterday is
as if the handrail greater
this is simple biograph the thief you think
about what it actually means this is an
incredible application of machine
intelligence and now work on  limitations
it is necessary that is was an isolated
test for a starter radiologist why
lying
one msn usually today bruise someone
they know more about the history of the
patient that now further help their
decisions for instance a history of
booze af en high-fiven
is  highly you for supplementary
information for you mens with that
bruise someone who make up demoniah
beyond oil the fantasy of the c  hest it
is something standard practical threesomes the
letter of us is really through as a
conclusion that is heavily not available in
this thesis at en dit is conjectured
de dit mist sweden comparison to urge
you must however a note that this
information may also benefit ikea just
as much de radiology and this seems like
suitable direction for future work
finally this is not the only yard wit and
for demoniah detection and it has been
compared to the state-of-the-art especially
14 diseases and this new techniques
once shows on a  war die als
level cap de peper for that language
speakers training uw on higher than
twenty one layer your network to acquire
some clever shenanigans is this was the
case for this it is wheelie delight
pictures see that is learning graham's can
help repayment
serious illnesses and provide higher
quality health care to more and more
people around the world is specially and
places where access to a experts
radiologists is limit it everyone
needs to care  but this if you with the
help of spreading the word and telling
the incredible story your tripods more
people please consider supporting als
breakfast rian
die as unnecessary many of you like crazy
for bitcoin anyway therapy
bitcoinadres is that psa lot in
the video description tag for  watching
and for your generous support na see you
next
hm
[Music]
ja